they tricked me bro i thought it was
just sweet and sweet and now
my blood pressure is going up
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
es el sho compreguntas calientes yalitas
de poyo a umas calientes
and today we're joined by jay balvin
he's the prince of reggaeton and the
king of streaming worldwide as well as a
five time latin grammy award winner
his latest album colores is out now the
newest singles maggie
and two veneno and as always the case
with jay balvin
more new music on the way but first a
gauntlet of very spicy chicken wings jay
balvin welcome to the show
thank you thank you thank you my man i
appreciate it man so grateful to be here
you know let's go let's see how that
goes man i always
i always check what you do man and now
it's my time to be here so let's
let's do it
[Music]
okay let's go
[Music]
this is the first one oh my god
i love chicken wings man so you've been
so successful in collaborating with
major american artists on spanish
language songs one that stands out to me
in particular is pharrell's hook on your
song safari
as someone who seems really committed to
redefining what it means to be
mainstream
do you take a certain sense of pride and
seeing so much reverse crossover
and pop music these days we are in a
great moment you know
there's a lot of artists that paid their
way for us before
you know daddy yankee or luisinian del
tevo calderon
omar you know it's a lot of legends in
the reggaeton that open
the doors for what we're doing now my
vision always been you know
crossover in spanish people are vibing
with what we say
even they don't know what we're saying
it's basically what happened with me
with hip-hop you know i was born in
colombia
and when i i used to just mumble
whatever you guys were saying i didn't
even know english you know
i still don't know english but i'm just
trying you know
to get some vibes but man like
definitely
it's beautiful to see how global and how
big and how huge
of the music in spanish it's been around
the world right now
[Music]
garlic and peppercini okay okay so we're
going to another level now right
taking it to another level
it's my favorite one in the lineup my
favorite one in the lineup but this is
delicious like
you do me do you do me a favor right now
you know like
well you know for now for now j belvin
you know
you might not be saying such nice things
as we move on down the line
so because of your meteoric rise some
music fans might think of you as an
overnight success story but those who
followed your journey know that it was a
nearly 10-year long grind before you
really started to break through as an
artist
what do you remember about the infinity
music days
of camping out outside of radio stations
and printing your own cds
besides being the artist i used to be my
own manager
you know when you see my name jose
speaking in the name of jay baldwin
you know so i was just picking up calls
like yeah yeah you know like oh you want
jay bobby so yeah let me talk to him
if the schedule is good let's see what j
bobbin thinks you know and but it was me
that's like that's where maybe el
negocio was born
yes 100 you know that's that's because
people used to be like whoa man like you
do everything you know like you're
you're the businessman you know like and
so someone when they call me oh you're
there you're in lagosia man i'm like
whoa
i like that quote you know so it's been
a process you know it's nothing that it
was just like from one day to another
you know so
it's it's really dope and that i can say
that i have history
[Music]
speaking of scots bonnet you know that
that was supposed to be my
artist name what yeah it's funny when i
was looking for my name i had a friend
you know
his name is uh fat al he's a rapper
and you know he was like bro you should
have like a name like
you know spicy name like scotch bonnet
and this is the first
time that i actually you know get the
you know see what you're talking about
what he was talking about so
now let's taste it what could have been
i could have been interviewing scotch
bonnet today yeah
yeah true like yo we're here with
scott's money
oh now we're on another level
[Music]
kick it a little bit kick it a little
bit
so architectural digest once described a
room in your median home as being the
world's dopest
shoe museum a sneaker closet
meticulously organized to display
whoa look at we have a dog that's my dog
enzo
it's always around i feel lucky that i
got i feel lucky i got a chance to meet
him today
he loved wings he loved wins i swear he
loved wings
are you still looking for those wu-tang
dunks or have you been able to track
those down
i'm still look i was actually making a
phone call yesterday
to get them they find they found a size
seven
so nope still on the hunt yeah
yeah we would find them on the right
price i guess
that name is scary oh my god okay
[Music]
fablet garlic and pepperoni and now
so fire is a good one so the streaming
revolution and apps like tic tac have
paved a way for artists to create
hits on a global scale unlike ever
before and in 2018 you actually
overthrew drake
as the most streamed artist in the
entire world
have you given any thought to how or why
reggaeton and latin music has seemed to
outpace the rest of the music industry
it's happy you know
it makes you feel it's it's a it's a
feeling good music you know like
it's all about emotions experience
people feel that we know with the beat
and the melodies we throw you know
so it's really dope you know that you
can
make people like oh besides the vibe
with the flows and the vibe
i want to really know what is he saying
so that's
we're adding some like education new
vibes to the
to the world
now we're talking as in spanish
oof this one is actually amazing
you dig it i think i know what you're
doing you're playing with me you know
you're like
let's give her a little you know nice
taste
you know little spice and then boom
jay balvin he knows how the game is
played all right j balvin we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that gram where we do a deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story so
last month you turned canelo alvarez's
entrance into a full-blown concert
did you guys discuss which songs to
perform in order to set a vibe for his
fight
okay now i'll stop feeling it
the canelo is right now one of the
biggest
fighters in the planet you know and it
hates his speak
okay and um he called me he was like
do you want to sing in my fight i was
like
bro i've been waiting for this moment
for like 10 years what are you talking
about
yes it was more than a statement you
know like first time canelo brings
you know one of his favorite artists to
the ring and
he killed it yeah no yeah speaking of
statements you know like that
that the the song i think might have
lasted longer than the fight
it's true but you know this is this is
crazy because when i talk to him
he definitely told me like listen i'm
gonna knock him out at the third round
i was like why are you talking about man
like he was like listen
i know i've been training i've been
studying and on the third round
canelo's daughter approached to me and
she well i love your songs
she starts singing my songs and she was
keep singing and singing
my song oh my god you know thank you and
boom
i saw there and he knocked the guy in
the third round and were like
what happened
[Music]
okay hmm
oh man it's getting spicy now
they tricked me bro i thought it was
sweet and sweet and now
my blood pressure is going up
i knew her so a star of your caliber
could easily stick to legacy media you
know
vogue covers and gq spreads but you
really get into the weeds of a lot of
your press appearances
talking sneakers on full-size run i've
seen you on
an economist podcast of course today
you're eating scorching hot chicken
wings with me on youtube
it's different from some of the pop
stars that you're compared to like drake
or kanye
where does that impulse come from wait
you can ask me a question again because
my
my bro my my head is on fire right now
i don't like to feel like a superstar i
still think that i'm not superstar i'm
just a big dreamer
because i know how it feels i've been a
fan of a lot of artists
that i see them and they act a certain
way when i
meet them it's a totally different
person
and that take them here
to hear being real is the best thing
that could ever happen to me because i
don't have to act
man i just want to be you know me you
know being real you know you can ask
your voice
after this if it was a piece of [ __ ] or
not
i don't know i just i just want to be me
you know you know
and i'm blessed i feel blessed that i
was raised in a real good way
[Music]
what's the story about this one torch
beer sauce
honey badger honey mustard so
don't let the honey fool you as i just
learned
the hard way okay it's like a it's like
a mustard from hell it's like a sweet
mustard from hell
okay be careful out there
oh bro this is dangerous yeah
[Music]
i'm gonna try a little bit wow
my god i'm getting chills and [ __ ]
so you're widely recognized for your
personal style but one of the most
underrated things about jay balvin in my
opinion is your watch game which has
been
chronicled and acclaimed by watch
experts and collectors
all over the internet i once saw you
wearing a rainbow daytona with the white
gold and
i don't know a ton about watches but i
do know that that one is extremely rare
of all the watches that you own which
one was the most difficult or
challenging to track down
the most difficult one it was a gift
that someone gave it to me
a guy came to me and was like listen i
respect you a lot and and i want to give
you this as a gift
i was like listen i cannot receive it
you know like i don't want you oh you
know favor
it was like if you don't receive it
you're not going to get out of this
country
so and i know he was saying for real so
so when so i said okay okay i'm gonna
get
okay but the story is beautiful because
i asked him like how does it feel
to be so powerful at your age he was my
same age and he answered me with the
same question
how does it feel to be so powerful at
your age
and i was like oh bro you're right
the power of music and the power that we
have
touch everybody's people life you know
so that is a richer meal you just won in
the world
i wasn't looking for it life just worked
in a mysterious way
which is the better swiss watchmaker in
your opinion
ap or patek well that's a good question
i mean historically patek they haven't
changed the shape
to takes new buyers they just keep it
real and keep it as simple as the
original shape it's like
when we're talking about a jordan 1
right right you know they still
you know they might change some colors
they might change something but
the shape is the shape and that's what
it makes a classic
but definitely ap they do grow with the
new generation which
i think is cooler too you know i vibe
with both but you know
when you know about watches you know you
know you don't boss them down
yeah i'm curious what you think about
that is as a watch purist and someone
who's really into watches because i
think you know a lot of people think
like if you ice it down or whatever if
you're adding diamonds to it
that's to me like i've been i've been
i'm always like i love to see my boys
growing up in the game you know like
artists that i've been supporting since
day one so they you know when they start
getting
money you know they start like iced in
you know buffs down
the first rolex and the first ap and the
first whatever
add a million in diamonds if you want
the real price of that watch
is going down because it's not original
you know like every time i see like
someone with a watch that is beautiful
and they add diamonds i'm like
no bro you did not
touch that so please keep your watches
original
you know respect the art respect the
the legacy
oh my god bro that bomb beyond insanity
this is the video that everybody want to
watch cheers my g
cheers cheers j belvin okay
oh yeah
yep this is toxic bro
i know but still eating it still going
in
my blood pressure
it's crazy it's crazy
[Music]
whoa but can't stop eating it can't stop
eating it
[Music]
so between new york miami and la is
there one of those cities that does
colombian food better than the others
i can talk bro
[Music]
i know
[Music]
careful around your eyes careful around
your eyes just don't touch your eyes
i know i know
meditation meditating let the yoga
exist bro
[Music]
new york might have the best colombian
food besides
colombia when everything happened in
colombia and everything was bad
with the past that way everybody knows a
lot of colombians escape from colombia
to new york
so when you walk in queens you find
places that taste even better
and more colombian than being in
colombia my foreign language skills are
pitiful but i want to at least
try to be able to talk about spicy food
all over the world
is there a colombian slang a phrase a
saying about eating super spicy food
that you can teach me
picante picante hasta la chima what does
that mean
it's like fire this is this spiciest
funk
picante hashimba
yeah i know speaking of picante
are you ready to move on to the next
sauce this is the eye of the scorpion
[Music]
let's go let's go let's go i mean
already been through this hell
i already seen the devil i talked to him
for a while
which one is this one i have the
scorpion hot sauce
smells but it's powerful like
yeah really close to to hell be careful
be careful
yeah okay let's go
just
[Music]
oh this will go through your throat bro
yeah
catches it but still going in just still
still
cleaning every wing i'm very oh my god
yeah yeah oh again
you've said that style is a passion of
yours on the same level as music and to
your credit you have some of the best
merch in the entire music industry
if you were to create a capsule
collection of hot ones
what would it look like i'll grab a pen
so i can take some notes
it could be like a lot of flames with
different colors
you know like the red the blue
the orange the you know like like maybe
around here
you know like different like or just
like one big flame here
they show like the degrees of hard day
going up and up and up and up and up and
up and up
a scoville scale like that'll measure
how spicy something is
like a scoville hoodie but that's
something quick we want to take a seed
you know and
we might come up with some crazy ideas
of course but
the scale is dope oh
[Laughter]
whoa is this the is this the spiciest
meal you've ever eaten
100 yeah
yeah 100 100 but this
right here you can kill people with this
yeah i know it's only a matter of time
oh police no joke great
[Music]
all right j balvin we're just about to
send you to a cryogenic chamber to
recover but before we send you
on your way your career you know it's
taken you around the world you've gotten
to work with so many industry titans and
met a bunch of heroes along the way
notably one that's of interest to me is
that you met the defining members of the
chicago bulls dynasty
all of them dennis rodman scottie pippen
and michael jordan i think i know the
answer to this question but just to make
it official
which one of those bulls legends left
the biggest impression on you and why
with michael jordan i stayed like four
or five
hours talking with him in paris the
whole night
so i had the chance to really
get to know a little bit of this legend
dennis the coolest man you know just as
just as you see it
scotty is definitely such a gentleman
man
such a gentleman man and michael has a
little bit of
all of them you know you can see like
the craziness a little bit
but you see the gentleman but you see
the attitude that you know that he know
who he is and he know
he know he is a living legend i love
all three but definitely can say that i
had a real long talk with michael jordan
because the legend right there and a hot
sauce
legend in the making and jay balvin
taking on the wings of
death and living to tell the story the
spiciest meal he's ever had in his life
but he completed it and he really
completed it and now jay balvin there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you my friend this camera
that camera
probably just the one you're looking at
let the people know what you have going
on in your life
listen i had a blast this is amazing
i just try how many one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
ten different types of health
in your mouth uh we're such a talenter
taunting guy that knows the right
questions and know what's up with your
career
so man i'm blessed um thank you thank
you for the opportunity to be here
if i'm not mistaken i'm the first latino
with you you're the first colombian
the first colombian ever on hot ones
let's go so you know columbia represent
latino gang thank you so much
love it man
[Music]
thank you great job developing great job
i got one of my best friends here and
he's gonna try this one because he's a
nice he's a guy that likes spicy things
okay andres this is my best friend
andres can you
okay this is my gift to you thank you
that's
so how much i love you okay
let's go
wait wait wait
[Laughter]
hippo
don't you bro this is
[Laughter]
breathe
oh my god i told you g
d
j but you got to you got to do something
nice for andres this afternoon you got
to do something nice for your
roll the boys
[Laughter]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and if you're thinking hey sean
that's a cool beanie i'd like to pick
one up for myself well guess what
you are in luck shop.firstweavefeast.com
has got you covered when it comes to
beanies
when it comes to sauces when it comes to
hoodies and a whole bunch of other stuff
like this
probably my favorite thing that we've
ever made la king's
hot ones hockey jersey that's right we
even have that at
shop.firstnewfeast.com assuming it
hasn't sold out by the time this end
card goes up
shop.firstbeatfeast.com
shop.firstwheatfees.com
shop.firstweavefeast.com for all your
sauces hoodies
and beanies and other stuff too
wrister hot ones now just a little bit
[Applause]
colder